Ciao Gu, una mattina mia madre decide di
farmi uno scherzo e decide di svegliarmi
con una trombetta per la bici, suonandomela nell'orecchio. Inutile dire che sono
saltato dal letto e ho buttato giù
tutti i santi dal calendario. Già che non ha
buttato giù la madre...è qualcosa di buono. Già che non glie l'ha
inserita questa trombetta nelle zone
recondite. Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
nuova puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema
della puntata di oggi è "Pesce d'Aprile"
Per un tema così importante ho pensato
di invitare all'interno degli studios
de casa mia una persona che in realtà
mi è stata raccomandata, cioè io me lo
ricordo quando aveva tipo sei anni,
adesso invece è un teppista ed è uno dei
migliori amici diciamo di mio cugino e
di mio fratello, uno di quegli amici che
ti porta in galera. Detto ciò vi presento Roshane. Dai non devi essere timido nel senso...
Partiamo dal presupposto che Roshane non ha mai visto
un Vita Buttata. No assolutamente no!
Non avevo idea di cosa fosse
Ma infatti lo sapevo che tu eri, diciamo...il nostro povero, che non me lo posso permettere...per guardarlo
Ora noi ascolteremo degli audio
legati agli scherzi e mi ha detto Enrico
che in passato avete fatto delle cose...da
non raccontare...esatto! Ti dico tu le
puoi raccontare tutte, sappi che io
alcune di queste non le monterò
Non ci rimanere male. Rimango fuori non in galera più che altro, quindi va benissimo!
Partiamo subito a vedere che cosa ci
dicono. Mi era trasferita da poco, avevo due
coinquilini e hanno ben deciso che nel weekend in cui io
non c'ero di rigirarmi la stanza al
contrario, ma non si parla solo dei
piccoli oggetti si parla di tutto
il letto, la scrivania, la porta! Avevano
scardinato la porta e l'avevano rimontata
al contrario. Perché ridi? Mi è venuta in mente una cosa. Cioè? Al tempo delle
convivenze...facciamo un cappello
introduttivo. Che ci crediate o no
Enrico e Roshane si sono conosciuti in
chiesa...pure Gianmarco poi...anche
Gianmarco è vero, prima di bruciarla poi
in realtà, però di base si sono
conosciuti in chiesa e a volte andavano in
questi ritiri spirituali, dove loro tutto
facevano tranne che...pregare...pregare fondamentalmente. Qual'è la cosa legata
alla stanza? Tre persone che ci avevano
chiuso fuori dalla nostra stanza...ok
...noi ovviamente ci dobbiamo vendicare
facendo sempre peggio. Siamo entrati nella
stanza loro passando dai balconi. Ma a che
piano? Sarà stato il secondo piano alla fine. Ah vabbè...
Cascavo sopra Enrico me salvavo, ritornavo
al quarto piano ritornavo
Allora quindi? Siamo entrati nella loro stanza, a
un certo punto ci siamo resi conto che
loro erano andati via dalla nostra
stanza. Abbiamo preso tutti i mobili, li
abbiamo alzati di peso e li abbiamo accatastati tutti nella nostra stanza, che
era una stanza che era un corridoio per
due persone. Ci stavano tutti sti letti, tutti
sti armadi accatastati sopra i nostri
letti, abbiamo lasciato dentro la stanza
soltanto il telefono, quello...il fisso, lì in mezzo, così non lo riuscivamo a staccare, che porobabilmente
era pure la cosa più semplice, era la spina però non ci riuscivamo vabbè. E questi sono rientrati...
questi sono rientrati dentro, hanno guardato non ci
stava niente! Non ci stava assolutamente niente!
Scusate ma io vi chiamo pe famme i traslochi
(Enrico) Ma la cosa bella poi che mentre tipo spostavamo un mobile, era tardi...ah vero...
...siamo passati davanti alla stanza del prete, che ha aperto la porta e ci ha visto (*risata*)...tipo i ladri...
che portavano via le cose. (Enrico) E la sua
risposta fu chiudere la porta...(*risata*)
Lui ci guardò soltanto, noi immobili e poi
chiude la porta, e noi rimaniamo là
interdetti per qualche secondo e poi
continuammo. Perché lui non le forze di
affrontarvi...si vabbè era esasperato. Ma ce ne stavano tante in realtà (Enrico). Mamma mia!
E' rientrato in camera e ha fatto "Dio ti prego cosa posso fare?"
Hey ciao Gu e ciao ospite, il pesce d'Aprile più bello che io abbia mai fatto
l'ho fatto a mia sorella tantissimi anni fa, perché serviva
un documento di nascita a scuola, non mi
ricordo, e con mia madre ho modificato
al computer il fatto che mia sorella fosse nata da
mia madre
Scrissi che era stata adottata...che genio...ha pianto per giorni...Questa è una cosa stupenda!
Lui se la taglia ancora, senza un cuore questo
ragazzo. Mamma mia regà questa è una
persona orribile. Ah io l'unica cosa che mi ricordo al momento
l'ho fatta però per punire una persona.
Era successo "L'11 Settembre", e questo
qui in classe se ne esce con una cosa tipo "Si ma sti c***i che sono morti". Io mi giro
verso di lui e ho fatto "Sai su un aereo c'era mia
madre", e lui è morto. Sull'aereo?...Lui ha preso un aereo
ed è morto. Però per punirlo. E mi ha chiesto scusa ma in realtà gli dicevo "Non è morta, però chiedi scusa alle
persone che hai offeso". Peccato che non sapesse
parlare inglese
Ciao Gu ciao ospite...ciao...lo scherzo più brutto che ho ricevuto
me lo hanno fatto i miei amici con un bambolotto
Siamo andati a fare un weekend  in una
casa in campagna di una mia amica
Per due giorni mi hanno torturato con questo
bambolotto facendomelo trovare ovunque
nonostante fossero passati due giorni
quindi pensavo che questo Nati Ora ormai mi
avesse abbandonato quindi lasciata, loro
invece hanno chiamato mio fratello e
l'hanno non so come dato a mio fratello.
Quando sono tornata la sera quindi a
casa, l'ho ritrovato nel letto di casa
mia, che stava lì che mi guardava
con del sangue che scendeva dalla bocca...geniale...ho ancora paura solo a raccontarlo
Questi è stupendo. Io mi sarei cacato sotto lo ammetto
Però saresti stato felicissimo?
Non tanto perché se era un Horror morivo
perché il negro muore sempre negli Horror, quindi,
per quello non troppo però...C'ha pure
un pezzo di cordone ombelicale attaccato...Madonna...mamma mia!
Lo scherzo più brutto che ho ricevuto per il pesce di Aprile è stato quello di mio fratello
che si era nascosto nella mia cabina armadio, erano le
due di notte, entro in camera e inizio a sentire dopo
qualche minuto dei rumori strani, boh
di fruscii, niente però di così esagerato,
tant'è che mi metto a dormire, questi rumori continuano
e io mi faccio prendere l'ansia
e arrivano poi a concludersi con il pianto
di un neonato, provenire all'interno della mia camera
Io mi sono letteralmente sentita male
ho iniziato a piangere, e la cosa che mi ha messo ancora più ansia è stata mio fratello uscire dall'armadio urlando
Nooo no ragazzi ma questo qui cioè
il pianto di un bambino neonato,
che proviene dalla tua cabina armadio
Ragazzi no. Io mi alzavo proprio subito e me ne andavo via. Oppure mi prendeva il matto, prendevo e con un
lanciafiamme entravo dentro, e mio
fratello...tu hai un lanciafiamme nella tua stanza?
Sisisi, ce l'ho vicino al comodino, c'è il
lubrificante e il lanciafiamme, e avolte sbaglio
E quindi se entravi col lubrificante
dentro la cabina...scivolava
Ciao Gu, allora lo scherzo più epico che io abbia
mai fatto è stato a due ragazzi miei
compagni di stanza in America per due
settimane, più grandi di me di tre anni, io ne
avevo 14. Praticamente per due settimane
mi hanno bullizzata trattandomi malissimo
usando il mio profumo, i miei vestiti
senza chiedermi nulla, e allora ho deciso
che nel viaggio di ritorno dovevano
pagarla. Ti dico solo che ho dato
loro della cioccolata lassativa e un
quadretto bastava per uno stitico e ne
hanno presi tra testa, ma io lo sapevo
perché erano delle ingorde assurde e quindi
sapevo che ne avrebbero mangiato parecchia.
E niente che dire, hanno c****o per 8 ore
Io avevo in mente di fare uno scherzo
insieme a una mia amica. Noi l'abbiamo, cioè
non era uno scherzo ma era una scommessa. Cioè?
Chi perdeva, non mi ricordo qual'era la scommessa
fortunatamente non ho perso io, doveva prendersi un
sonnifero e un lassativo. Immaginati il
risveglio di questa persona. Ma l'hanno fatto? Si certo ha fatto la scommessa. E il risveglio è stato...
Eh un risveglio di merda, decisamente. Ma ragazzi, ma da dove l'avete preso? Tanto le tagliate ste cose no?
...per farti capire...Ciao Gu
io nella mia vita non ho fatto tanti
scherzi ma ne ho fatto solamente uno al mio
attuale ragazzo e praticamente io ho
comprato su Amazon la carta per fare
i tatuaggi finti e c'ho stampato sopra la
faccia del mio ragazzo e una scritta
"Ti amo" e poi il nostro soprannome
imbarazzante che voglio tenere segreto
Ho finto di essere andata ad una festa,
senza averglielo detto ovviamente
di essermi ubriacata e di avermi fatto, cioè di
essermi fatta fare un tatuaggio in casa
Gli ho fatto vedere i tatuaggi che sembravano
veri con la sua enorme faccia sulla mia
coscia. Beh tu hai fatto dei nuovi
tatuaggi, facciamoli vedere perché sono
dei tatuaggi abbastanza...adulti possiamo dirlo?
Si, gli ultimi sono Rufy di
One Piece, ovviamente Son Goku e qui ci sta...spetta, eccolo, aspetta, togli la mano, se riesci a
togliere la mano un secondo. Eccolo! Naruto. Naruto.
Stavi morendo?...Al mare una volta io...non
era proprio un tatuaggio. Che hai fatto? Con una ragazza
con cui stavo...bene...lei si è addormentata in una
posizione che mi permetteva di
divertirmi con la crema e gli disegnai
la sagoma di un pene che usciva dalla mutanda...Lei non si accorse di niente. Quando si svegliò che
ovviamente avevo già levato le cose, andò
in giro con sta abbronzatura e sto pene
che era appoggiato come se si fosse addormentata. Cioè nel senso che si era? Ma fatto pure bene
perché poi la crema s'era pure un po'
sciolta e quindi sembrava pure un po'... una
cosa brutta. La chiave della felicità è non
fidanzarsi con te? Con me si, probabilmente si.
Tu sei fidanzato vero? Da quanto?
Un anno e otto mesi. Relazione più lunga? No. Sappi
che questo video lo vedrà Camilla (Enrico)
Eh scialla. Eh Bianca(Enrico)...Uuu Luigi. Ah in tutto questo mio fratello è gay se tu non...
*risate*
Aspetta un secondo gli scrivo al volo, tu intanto
intrattieni. Eh che faccio?
Lo scherzo più bello che abbia mai fatto
involontariamente sia stato ai miei
genitori quando sono nata, dato che sono
nata il primo di Aprile, e scherzo ancora
più bello l'ha fatto mia sorella sempre ai miei genitori
due anni dopo nascendo anche lei il primo d'Aprile
Beh Enrico e mia madre sono nati il
13 maggio tutti e due. Io penso non c'ho familiari nati...
Tu quando sei nato? 20 ottobre. Bilancia? Si. Ascendente bilancia, che non so assolutamente cosa
voglia dire però m'hanno detto sta cosa. Un peso forma
(Enrico) Lo sai che io una volta mi sono...Tu non sei nato bilancia...Una volta io mi
sono svegliato che ho fatto gli auguri alla Sirva non sapendo che fosse il mio compleanno
Enrico...Cioè te non sei in questo mondo, io una volta citofono, lui "Chi è?"
"Guglielmo. Guglielmo chi?" Cioè cioè
(Enrico) Non era al telefono con Gabriele?
Anche credo. "Enrico", al telefono con la porta aperta
"mi raccomando mi porti il pacco che mi
è arrivato da Amazon? Certo!" Arriva da me "Me lo
sono dimenticato. Come hai fatto a
dimenticartelo? Te l'ho detto che avevi
un piede fuori!". Allora io propongo di
fare una cosa
siccome veramente qua sta diventando
l'asilo, l'asilo! Vado a prendere uno
stipendio per aver fatto il baby sitter,
per un'ora a questi due, l'altro non potete
vederlo. Io direi di prenderci una pausa,
altrimenti facciamo Il Signore degli
Anelli, solamente scritto col c**o perché cioè.... Ormai capito "c**o" e "hahahh", così è diventata questa sera
Il suo umorismo è più basso del mio, io non ho riso.
Hai un po' fatto "così"? Ho sorriso. Ci prendiamo un
momento di pausa, la settimana prossima postiamo la seconda parte
Mmm che brivido eh? Non vedo l'ora di vederla. Ragazzi Ciao. Ciao. Si può fare
meglio. Ora io direi ci prendiamo una pausa  ok?
Andiamo a prendere un pochino di
pesce ok? Che sembra il c***o
*Risate*
Molto, veramente molto. Per il bene
vostro, per il bene mio, io direi di
prenderci un attimo un momento di pausa
perché qua ci stanno Terry e Maggie che
veramente stanno scavando nella bassezza
dello humor cioè...no secondo me il primo andava bene. Ci vediamo la prossima settimana, nel frattempo vi
invito a iscrivervi, a commentare qua
sotto e soprattutto ad attivare la
campanella in modo da non perdervi
quella che sarà la seconda meravigliosa
puntata di questo tema. Saluta tu. Ciao
Tu lo fai? Certo. Che cos'è? Dabbare
Oddio quanto sei giovane. Quanti anni hai? Te no?
Te pare che io a 31 anni vado a Dabbare? 31 anni ce ne ho 25 ce ne ho. Ah quindi sei un c******e te
*risate*
In realtà a 25 sei giovane